what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around of our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors that you may have missed
over the course of the week and let's
get right into it because you guys don't
feel like waiting on all this stuff so
according to hollywood insider casey
walsh marvel studios is looking at
bringing back a villain that's going to
be changed a little bit to serve as a
mentor for a young
superhero now as you guys can imagine
from this bit of news speculation of
rumors abound right everybody's just
throwing out all these ideas now one of
the first things that people kind of
look at here is they don't really
believe this is kingpin one because
kingpin is seemingly already coming back
in hawkeye it seems to be another one of
those things where it's just the worst
kept secret in hollywood so it wouldn't
really make any sense that there's an
inside rumor that like marvel studios is
gonna bring back a villain to mentor a
young hero when one we already know that
villain is coming back and two who would
kingpin mentor
like
prince pen
i don't know
it's a terrible joke the important thing
here
is that the most popular theory going on
right now is that marvel studios is
going to bring back eric killmonger to
mentor shuri now i don't know if that's
true but to be honest with you guys
i think that would actually be a great
concept and on the surface we could look
at the events of black panther one and
say not a chance literally eric
killmonger was a guy who basically
almost killed a child and left him for
dead and then took over wakanda and
ruled it with an iron fist but here's
the thing about eric killmonger and it's
one of the things i love the most he's
not a straight villain right he's not a
straight guy where he's like okay now
that i've taken over wakanda we're gonna
blow up the world because that's what
villains do everyone's gonna die but us
now the motivations of eric killmonger
were actually quite selfless if you look
at his motivations in the film that
wakanda basically had the ability to
offer assistance to the black community
across the world but simply remained
hands off and that his goal was to
actually fix that problem a lot of that
seemed to be rooted in the motivations
that his father had when he basically
defected not really defective but when
he kind of betrayed wakanda by selling
weapons off to different people and so
eric killmonger isn't really doing it at
least he wasn't really doing it for the
purpose of just acquiring his own
individual wealth i mean there were some
like narcissistic aspirations that he
had going on there that can't really be
denied but despite all of that eric
killmonger was capable as hell and he's
one of those characters that i still say
to this day marvel made a massive
mistake killing him off they never
should have killed off eric killmonger
in black panther one never ever ever
ever ever if they were gonna kill off
villains that's fine eric killmonger
should have stayed alive because his
character was so phenomenal and there
was so much they could have done with
him that it was a waste but one of the
big theories that's been going around
for a number of years since black
panther came out is that one we didn't
actually see eric killmonger die we just
saw him collapse and contextually we
assumed that he was dead two from what
we saw with everett k ross wakanda seems
to have the ability to bring people back
from the dead basically at least back
from the brink of death and so it's not
outside the realm of possibility that
eric killmonger could be restored by
wakanda now the biggest issue you run
into here is is there trust enough in
wakanda to bring eric killmonger back
the idea though is that seemingly at the
end of his life when he was basically
there with t'challa there was some
remorse there right in the sense that i
don't know he fully repented or fully
felt bad about all the things he'd done
but he believed in wakanda right he
loved wakanda he was not that dissimilar
from t'challa in terms of his
perspective of wakanda itself he simply
wanted to see them go one step further
and what different him from t'challa is
that eric killmonger had the philosophy
by any means necessary and so because of
that it was not that far of a stretch to
believe that shuri in them could bring
killmonger back and if his character arc
kind of reaches this conclusion which is
okay look i kind of did some some pretty
crappy stuff but at the end of the day
i'm sure i could be a good guy now he'd
be a great mentor to sure he'd be a
great way to teach shuri what she needs
to know to become an effective combatant
and to become an effective leader now a
lot of that would be a role that would
be assigned to t'challa but as we know
with the unfortunate passing of chadwick
boseman that's not really a possibility
so in my mind eric killmonger is the
next best choice having said that let me
know what villain you would want to see
come back in the mcu to mentor a younger
hero but moving on we got our first
sneak peek at spiderverse 2. and when i
say sneak peek what i basically mean is
it looks like miles morales is fighting
miguel o'hara for a little bit they're
tumbling through the multiverse but it
looks pretty wonky right like the
animation and everything looks pretty
wild to be honest with you guys i think
that what sony's doing here is kind of a
slingshot effect right and i've said
this for a while that what they're doing
is they're they gave a spider-verse
which was like a full-on animated film
and it was phenomenal right we got like
spider-ham and all that kind of stuff so
i was like hey there's some zany
spider-man out there i think what this
movie's doing is kind of going in the
extreme right giving us this kind of
crazy wild just out there animation and
then slingshotting back to something a
little more tangible which is a
crossover between animated miles morales
and tom hall and spider-man we already
know that sony and marvel studios are
working on a new trilogy of movies for
tom hall and spider-man so it would make
perfect sense to me that if they're
really going to bring this trilogy
closer in line with the spider-verse
that exists out there meaning tom
holland is not going to be just some
spider-man out there just kind of doing
his own thing never crossing over with
anybody else that we would see an
eventual crossover event and to keep
things from just being a little too
extreme too fast they're sort of easing
us into it regardless of whether they're
doing that or not though i'm hyped about
spider-man into the spider-verse that
movie was phenomenal i loved it it was
it was one of the best spider-man movies
that i think i'd ever seen in quite some
time and it left me with this desire to
see more spider-man right like we know
miguel o'hara was like the post-credits
kind of ending teaser so we're like okay
we're getting miguel o'hara at a future
point in time but i want to see more
besides him i want to see different
versions of spider-man now if you guys
want to know more about the spider-verse
we're actually covering that over a
comedy explain shameless self-promotion
but we're covering it over there which
will basically give us the whole
spider-verse event once we're done and
then we're going to combine all of that
into dan slot's entire spider-man run
which is everything from like big time
to basically the starting off point for
peter parker under dan's slot running
all the way up to like spider island
when everybody basically ends up being
turned into a spider in new york and a
superior spider-man when dr octopus
takes over the body of peter parker and
then going into spider-verse and then
going into all-new all different marvel
and all that stuff right we're covering
a ton of stuff but it's gonna be a
massive thing if i'm being honest with
you guys i imagine that video might be
close to 24 hours it's going to be
insane how long that video is moving on
though for all you guys who are fans
like me of batman the animated series i
think you will be happy to know that at
la comicon
kevin conroy the voice of bruce wayne
batman himself in batman the animated
series actually came out and said the
entire cast is reuniting for an audio
drama and i am excited about that i
don't really know what form this is
going to take and in fact i think it was
just kind of teased and it's like a
thing they're going to be doing if
anything i believe this is kind of a
test bed right like we know that warner
brothers is bringing back batman the
animated series but honestly as popular
as that show was and it's popular as it
will be now that it's coming back i
could see them wanting to expand out a
little bit and say look let's do a
little bit more than just batman the
animated series let's take it back to
the day the retro stuff right like the
batman radio shows and things like that
you know podcasts are becoming ever
popular so it makes sense that they
would take that concept apply it to a
podcast form and kind of go forward from
there we just have to hope we don't get
like a war of the worlds kind of
situation you guys know about that when
they originally did war of the worlds
there were people who were tuning in
they thought it was an actual alien
invasion they were like calling the cops
and stuff they were panicking if you
don't believe me look it up it's crazy
right like people were idiots back then
but it was it was nuts regardless let's
continue on spider-man no way home is
apparently projected to make 200 million
dollars on opening weekend if i'm being
honest with you guys
i think that's a conservative estimation
i mean i think the movie's gonna make
like a billion dollars opening weekend i
think it's gonna get close to maybe like
three maybe 350. and here's the reason
why i say this is because i will still
say to this day even with avengers end
game and like infinity war i have never
seen so much hype surrounding a comic
book movie before even when you looked
at the events that went on with like
avengers in game and the lead up to it i
mean sure there were like rumors and
there were plot leaks and things like
that but nothing on the order of this
right this this this is i mean it's
taking on a whole life of its own right
like all this insanity and all this
madness with like all this stuff going
on involving like spider-man no way home
it's almost like its own character right
like it could be a villain in the in the
movie right like you get like all these
villains like doctor octopus and those
guys we've seen in the trailer plus like
the leaks and rumors right like leaks
and rumors man
i don't know but regardless man i mean
it's not the biggest piece of news ever
it's not really a rumor or anything like
that but honestly i think that's a
conservative estimate that's my question
for you guys do you guys think that this
movie will actually break the 200
million dollar mark that's being
projected and get closer to like 300 or
400 how much money do you think this
movie is going to bring in worldwide
in its opening weekend i'm curious but
moving over here to video games for a
second honestly i didn't really see a
whole lot of news and rumors surrounding
video games and i was too keen on
reporting here but apparently vince
impella is being brought on to lead the
battlefield team to both fix a lot of
the bugs and stuff like that that they
have but also expand the battlefield
universe and that does not surprise me
in the slightest so here's a quick
little bit of history for those of you
guys who don't know who vince zampella
is so you guys have all heard of the
call of duty franchise right well
zampella was one half of the creative
team that brought the entirety of call
of duty to fruition from the first game
running all the way up to modern warfare
2. and the reason why i say modern
warfare 2 is because there was a lot of
controversy and a lot of really just
chaos going on on the back end with
modern warfare 2 that led to like
lawsuits and claims of like contracts
being breached and things like that but
ultimately uh zampella and really west
they both left infinity ward and then
went on to launch respawn entertainment
now for a lot of people who are just die
hard fans of zampela and west they
believe in them no matter what and the
first real game they released at that
point in time was titanfall which you
guys have heard recently has actually
been removed from stores although it is
still playable though for how long i'm
not really sure but titanfall was their
first real release and
for the game that it was it was okay but
it left a lot of people just kind of
disappointed because what they were
expecting was a kind of remake
restructured version of call of duty
because that's the franchise that west
and zempela had really made their bones
off of now eventually they rallied and
they came back with titanfall 2 which
was phenomenal but these guys have been
around the block for quite some time and
so because of that it makes perfect
sense if somebody like zampella would be
brought in to both fix all the bugs that
are going on in battlefield because the
newest iteration was just bad with all
the bugs and everything the the whole
campaign and everything was cool but the
playability was a bit of a struggle
which again that's part and parcel to
gaming development these days right they
usually release incomplete games and
then charge you for the patches to fix
the game so sure you're paying 60 bucks
but when it's all said and done you're
basically paying 120 dollars for a
completed video game plus whatever dlc
they offer along the way and then in
turn he's also going to expand the
battlefield universe but i'm curious to
see what this is going to look like
because i have to believe
there's got to be some beef going on
behind the scenes right like literally
battlefield was in a lot of ways the big
competitor to call of duty you guys
remember those days back in the day
battlefield 3 versus modern warfare 2. a
lot of people were kind of going back
and forth really was battlefield 3
versus modern warfare 2 black ops if you
want to go that way but like the fan
base was split like either you were a
battlefield fan or you were a call of
duty fan you were never really both it
was only ever one or the other i mean i
always felt that was kind of silly and i
always thought battlefield 3 was fun
uh yeah i always had a great time
playing that game but the important
thing here is that there's probably a
little bit of beef there right like
battlefield is bringing on a former call
of duty developer
to fix its game
and expand its universe
so i'm curious to see how the community
is taking this but moving back into the
swing of things with like movies and
shows and different things like that
apparently kobe smulders is coming back
for secret invasion and while that's not
the most important thing ever honestly
i'd be surprised if you guys cared what
this does really do is ask the question
what's secret invasion gonna look like
i'm not entirely sure what this is going
to look like right because in the comics
in fantastic four number 257 galactus
destroyed what was it tan rax for the
homeworld of the scrolls so like he
basically devoured their homeworld and
then you go into the events of
annihilation where what was left of the
the scroll home world had basically
spread across the rest of the empire so
they didn't really have like a true home
per se they were really more like nomads
right just refugees and then when like
the annihilation event happened so like
annihilus basically invading the main
marvel universe from the negative zone
and just
led a rampage across the universe itself
and almost destroyed it that like the
scrolls didn't really have a place to go
and so when you went into like ryan
michael bendis's new avengers and then
the illuminati and all that kind of
stuff you ended up finding out those
guys confronted the scrolls because of
the preschool war and said don't bring
your conflict to earth but because earth
had such a tactical advantage that the
scrolls basically did it anyway by
initiating the secret invasion event
that in effect scrolls were secretly
replacing superheroes and just
high-ranking individuals on earth in
order to basically subjugate and control
the earth but galactus doesn't exist
maybe it's because of the fact that the
scroll homeworld was destroyed by the by
the cree but what we've seen from the
scrolls is they largely seem to be
benign in the sense that like they're
helping humanity and like humanity's
helping them so it seems to be very much
like a symbiotic relationship as opposed
to a parasitic one now we have heard
little bits over the course of like
their appearances like captain marvel
things like that where basically we've
been told the scrolls are a lot more
deceptive and duplicitous than they
initially appear to be that they're
coming off as allies when they're
actually the bad guys and that would be
a pretty interesting turn of events
right where basically captain marvel was
fighting on the wrong side the whole
time where like the cree are the actual
good guys in all of this and the scrolls
legitimately are the bad guys i think
that'd be an interesting twist i don't
know if that's really going to be the
case but the normal motivation you would
expect to see from the scrolls doesn't
really seem to exist here in the mcu
unless their world was destroyed by
galactus and we just don't know it yet i
mean i guess it'd be an interesting way
to introduce this character but the
scrolls have historically been a pretty
war-bound race i mean they weren't
initially in the comics they were
actually a peaceful race in the comics
and it wasn't until the kris started a
war with the scrolls that they basically
reverted into their more like barbarian
states so it's a little interesting i
mean there is a lot more to the scrolls
than that this is not comics explains we
don't need to do like a whole history of
the scrolls but nonetheless i am curious
to see how this events are going to
unfold like what's the motivation of the
scrolls secretly replacing humanity
because if anything it kind of seems
like a dick move for people who are
helping you right i mean i i don't
really know i'm kind of curious to see
what it looks like but regardless going
into our final piece of news here and
this is one of the more interesting
things according to a reddit post from
an insider loki 2 is going to start
filming in the summer of next year and
is apparently expected to finish by the
time ant-man 3 comes out and i don't
think that's a coincidence because as
you guys know kane the conqueror is the
main villain for ant-man 3 and kane the
conqueror is basically the guy who
replaced or took over the tva following
the death of a mortis and the loki tv
show so it makes perfect sense to me and
i think this is really really cool i
think loki will be the first show to
really actually cross over
with a movie not in the sense that like
you bounce literally from like ant-man
to loki to ant-man to loki or anything
like that but like ant-man gives you a
set of events and then loki gives you
the other half of those sets of events
right so maybe loki appears in ant-man
kwanomania doing something but it's like
if you want to know what he was doing
that led to this go check out the loki
tv show and if you want to know what
he's going to be doing after this go
check out the loki tv show or something
along those lines right but seeing
characters kind of crossing over
zigzagging from the tv shows to the
movies i think this might be the first
real time that actually happens and if
it is i'm excited about that i'm also a
little bit nervous because i feel like
that could be a little confusing for the
average viewer but i don't necessarily
know if that's going to be the case i
mean the only concern that i have here
if loki and ant-man 3 really do cross
over is that it could be a little
jarring and maybe a little confusing for
the average viewer but as long as they
do it in a way that makes sense right
you just watch the whole loki show you
watch the whole movie quantum mania and
then as you're doing that you're like oh
yeah okay cool i remember that moment in
quantum mania so that's what loki was
doing right that kind of light bulb goes
off i don't think they'll make it overly
convoluted and overly complicated the
mcu is predicated on simplicity but let
me know what you guys think but with
that being said we're gonna bring this
episode to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace